mais d'abord comme un air de déjà vu sur
le front du coc vite 19 en indre et
loire le nombre de patients actuellement
hospitalisé pour coronavirus flirtent à
nouveau vous le voyez avec les sommets
191 malades c'est à peine moins qu'en
avril au plus fort de la crise même
tendance en réanimation
résultat le chru de tours doit à nouveau
des programmes et les opérations
chirurgicales dit non urgentes
romain delville concrètement le plan
blanc déclenchée au chu de tours
ce sont 20% d'opérations qui sont
déprogrammés et reporté l'idée c'est
d'apporter du renfort des autres
services vers le service de réanimation
la quarantaine de professionnels
nécessaires on ne peut la trouver que si
et seulement si on les reprend dans les
services et donc d'où la déprogrammation
alors c'est pas une déprogrammation un
taux trompe apportant 20 % mais ça ne
conduit en parallèle à fermer quelques
unités une unité en orthopédie quelques
lire neurochirurgie quelques lits en
chirurgie pédiatrique
c'est des programmations sont la
conséquence de personnel qui manque au
chu il y a les soignants dits fragiles
qui sont retirés du travail les
personnels positif même asymptomatiques
qui sont écartés sept à dix jours
le taux d'absentéisme est de 9% et demi
soit un point de plus que d'habitude
soit environ 100 personnes
en ce qui concerne l'activité qu'ovide
33 personnes sont en réanimation pour un
total de 88 patients hospitalisés et 88
qui était 93e sont quand même des
chiffres qui nous avaient pas là une
grande prudence ce d'autant que le ch
vous le savez c'est le seul chu de la
région et que d'autres départements
notamment l'eure-et-loir sont confrontés
aujourd'hui à une montée en charge
encore plus importantes et sont amenés à
nous transférer des patients très
régulièrement depuis le début du mois
nous avons accueilli une vingtaine de
patients d'autres celles d'autres
départements que le nôtre dans la course
contre la montre qui oppose le
coronavirus ces variants et le vaccin le
chru de tours anticipe une montée en
puissance de la prise en charge de
patients qu'ovide associé à un manque de
personnel
la perturbe pour la troisième fois en un
an l'organisation de l'hôpital d'où le
recours aux des programmations